it has been a busy couple of weeks for
food pantries families are finishing up
their last payment from supplemental
nutrition assistance program known as
snap there endemic families were able to
receive an extra payment flea that has
now come to an end Victoria Saha joins
us from Catholic Charities as they're
seeing a huge need and families asking
for help
Charities is usually stocked up with
food items but now with many families
without the extra money in their pocket
there's a worry that these items will be
flying off the shelves sooner than later
cbx I mean this is like one meal
literally the bills will be gone today
mom of three carlisia Martin finds
herself back at Catholic Charities I'm
just grateful for whether they do give
us it does help like Manny it's been a
struggle for her to afford even the
basic necessities I don't know what's
which is most the bread or the water
Martin is just one of the 400 000
families in Nevada who won't be
receiving an extra snap payment the
extra payments started during the
pandemic so families could afford
groceries is this even enough for your
family
appreciate it Catholic charity serves
about 150 people a day many are new
faces we are seeing a lot of anxiety a
lot of fear so you see fear and the
people that you serve but what is your
biggest fear uh I'm concerned that we're
not going to be able to be able to serve
as many people as we'd like
turning because the extra payments are
ending at a time where prices aren't
what they used to be or the most
vulnerable are the most affected and
they are the ones offering that suffer
in silence it's scary to me because I
look in the eyes of the people that we
serve and the items they do give out
will be stretch thin out of a course of
30 45 days that we have to wait this
doesn't last very long with the future
still uncertain Catholic Charities says
they are hopeful they'll still be able
to offer a little something for everyone
Victoria Saha 8 News Now